you don't poke the
bear you you told the pans that it was I
just I just told you why I did
it what can you clarify that though what
I I spoke English I just told you
anybody that knows anything about sports
knows you don't poke the bear that's my
answer what do you feel like about just
better you like the way you guys comped
tonight I was proud of him you know we
we had a bad first quarter shooting wise
obviously uh but they only scored 26 in
that quarter so uh that really wasn't a
bad quarter except for our shooting but
the next three quarters you know we
outscored them uh 92 to 87 the last
three quarters I know that's not a win
uh but their competitiveness was off the
charts and the execution you know keeps
getting better for a team that's never
played together I was proud of them
tonight I thought they did a good
job pop just one more on the uh what you
said to the fans was that something
that's all I that's all I need to say I
don't know how you want me to do you
want me to make up a different answer no
I'm asking you gave the answer I gave
you the answer I'm going to ask there's
no other questions that need to be asked
you didn't want Ka anybody else to have
a you didn't you didn't want kawhai to
be motivated by the booing is that what
you
mean you know exactly what I mean you
don't poke the bear okay